[Applauso]
questa sono io a tre anni
[Musica]
Queste sono io oggi
Direi che da Caravaggio all'arte
rupestre è proprio un attimo Ma cosa è
successo nel mezzo Facciamo un passo
indietro riavvolgiamo il nastro e
partiamo dall'inizio
ho sempre amato disegnare la piccola
disegnare mi faceva sentire come una
Rockstar capace di dare una forma a
qualunque cosa io avessi nella testa
disegnare mi permetteva di rappresentare
la mia vita tingendola con un po' di
magia qui per esempio mi vedete al circo
mentre dormono animale fantastico e
faceva sentire libera e non giudicata
quando disegnavo tutte le mie paure
andavano via o meglio quasi tutte le mie
paure Perché il buio i mostri che vivono
al buio continuavano decisamente a farmi
paura
la bambina ero robusta è molto più alta
di tutte le altre bambine della mia età
erobullizzata per la mia forma così
dissonante dallo stereotipo del bambino
contenuto e complesso
dentro soffrivo Allora disegnavo
dipingevo creavo manufatti con carta
igienica e colla vinilica avendo una
passione sfrenata per Art Attack Insomma
addobbavo il mio mondo di colore
accoglienza accettazione e serenità
con il passare degli anni crescendo
L'arte è stata l'amica che non mi ha mai
abbandonata Lei è sempre stata lì a
concedermi lo spazio il tempo di cui
avevo bisogno ogni volta che ne avevo
bisogno sì perché lei per me è la
capacità di raccontare storie che vanno
oltre i confini del foglio della tela o
del muro L'arte è una storia che non
smette mai di esistere e di evolvere non
solo la storia di chi disegna dipinge o
crea l'opera ma è anche la storia tutti
coloro che guardando quella opera ci si
riconoscono o riconoscono qualche cosa
della loro vita
fino a vent'anni non ho trovato una
forma espressiva che sentissi mia che
desse voce al mio mondo interiore
parlando al tempo stesso anche di ciò
che mi circondava
poi due momenti hanno segnato la mia
vita
nel 2009 inizia a soffrire di ansia e di
attacchi di panico nel 2012 dopo ANSA e
panico arriva lei la non resta nervosa è
un momento delicato e complesso della
mia vita e questa stessa complessità si
manifesta anche nei miei disegni che
diventano tristi Cupi spesso quasi non
riesco a disegnare posso dire che
qualcosa in me si spegne perdendo il
colore
quando soffre di un disturbo del
comportamento alimentare fai davvero
molta fatica a riconoscere ed esprimere
le tue emozioni perché il tuo controllo
è tutto diretto al cibo in questa quasi
totale incapacità di capire ciò che mi
stava succedendo disegnare mi ha
permesso di dare una tridimensionalità a
quello che stavo provando mi ha permesso
di riconoscerlo mi ha permesso di
mantenere il contatto con me stessa e
con la mia natura mi ha dato la forza il
coraggio di chiedere aiuto così un passo
dopo l'altro pian piano sono riuscita a
riappropriarmi delle mie emozioni le ho
sentite di nuovo attraversare il corpo e
ho dato loro una voce
da tutto quel buio convertito in nuovo
colore nasce nel 2014 il mio Alter Ego
di libris Forse è la stessa linea nera
che in quello stesso anno comitato fra
le scapole per ricordarmi il mio passato
di linea ma lasciarmelo alle spalle che
in un qualche modo evolvendo mi dà
l'ispirazione
il nome si ispira alle ribresco
personaggio pittrice Digital faro di
Virginia Woolf per chi non l'avesse
letto Il romanzo è diviso in tre sezioni
di cui l'ultimo chiamata appunto il faro
è il momento in cui librisco dopo dieci
anni nella storia finalmente alla sua
visione finalmente riesce a completare
il suo quadro quel quadro che per tutto
il romanzo rimane incompiuto la storia
di questo personaggio rispecchia
perfettamente ciò che di libri si
rappresenta per la mia vita è il momento
in cui finalmente mi ritrovo è il
momento in cui riesco a chiudere il
cerchio
i primi disegni sono istantanei di vita
quotidiana lasciate su foglietti volanti
E da questo momento che la voce di
libris acquisisce un'impennata di volume
da piano a Forte un po' come quando
siamo in macchina e alla radio passa la
nostra canzone preferita alziamo il
volume talmente tanto che praticamente
potrebbero sentirci anche dalla
provincia vicina
dal 2014 questi piccoli grandi e
semplici omini iniziano ad abitarmi
iniziano ad abitare il mio mondo
letteralmente invadendolo si stanziano
diventano il canale emotivo ed evocativo
con cui comunico all'esterno tutto
quello che per me è importante con la
loro semplicità mi insegnano
quotidianamente a togliere il superfluo
per lasciare spazio all'essenziale lo
fanno con pochi tratti poche parole in
modo che i concetti siano immediatamente
Chiari
una volta una mia amica di sei anni mi
ha chiesto perché i tuoi omini non hanno
nella bocca nel naso domanda più che
lecita
il mio Alter Ego di libris ha solo i
suoi occhi perché è da voce e parla la
lingua del suo mondo interiore la sua
voce il suo lessico è fatto di parole
quotidiane che possano parlare al tempo
stesso di temi molto importanti e grandi
come l'amore l'uguaglianza diritti umani
che di cose divertenti e spensierate
nel linguaggio della semplicità si può
parlare di ogni cosa anche la più
difficile che riusciamo a immaginare
Ho immaginato questo processo come una
matassa di filo ingarbugliato A primo
impatto ci sembra un grande caos poi
improvvisamente troviamo il capo del
filo lo tiriamo e ogni groviglio ogni
intreccio si spiega si scioglie
Che cosa fanno questi omini
traducono il caos e lo rendono semplice
immediato
in un mondo sempre più tecnologico e
caotico in cui fin da bambini sia
sottoposti a tantissimi stimoli
disegnare è importante perché disegnare
Non solo ci fa apprendere il mondo
circostante ma è anche un potente
strumento per esprimere il nostro
vissuto interiore un bambino che disegna
è un bambino stimolato a creare il mondo
anziché subirlo pensiamo ai videogames
attraverso i disegni i bambini ci
parlano e spesso ci dicono cose che non
sono ancora in grado di dire con le
parole che hanno a disposizione
quando avevo 10 anni dipingevo come
Raffaello mi ci è voluta una vita per
dipingere come un bambino
Picasso descrive benissimo con questa
frase L'intreccio che esiste nei bambini
corpo mente ed emozioni sono tutt'uno
senza sovrastrutture ho scelto di
condividerla con voi oggi perché penso
che ci sia davvero bisogno di questi
intreccio ci sia bisogno di non perderlo
di vista di essere adulti consapevoli e
capaci di dare voce al nostro mondo
interiore conservando però quello
spirito di spensieratezza e di
leggerezza di cui parla Calvino quando
dice planare sulle cose dall'alto non
avere macigni sul cuore
Avete mai pensato a quale possa essere
l'etimologia della parola semplice
semplice deriva dal latino Simplex
composto a due radici la radice Sem 1 e
la radice Black che troviamo nel verbo
flettere piegare intrecciare piegato
intrecciato una sola volta
tant'è che al termine semplice si
contrappone al termine complesso con più
lettere piegato intrecciato più volte
l'etimologia ci dice che il semplice non
è un origami spiegato tante volte al
tempo stesso la piega singola ci
suggerisce che il semplice non è
qualcosa di banale di Palese di già
immediatamente svelato ma è qualcosa che
appunto va aperto va spiegato
in questo senso penso che dovremmo
davvero rivalutare l'importanza della
semplicità nella nostra vita non solo di
cose semplici ma anche di un linguaggio
semplice che possa permetterci di
svelare il segreto che sta dietro e
dentro a quella piega
Sì perché semplificare non è un
esercizio di banalizzazione quanto più
un approccio di avvicinamento alla
nostra essenza alla nostra autenticità
un approccio capace di togliere tutte
quelle sovrastrutture che di continuo ci
dimentichiamo intorno
pensavate fosse finita qui no
adesso i protagonisti diventate voi
tutti voi anche voi là in fondo
durante
una delle mie mostre ho chiesto ai
partecipanti di Prendere parte a un
gioco
a partire da alcune suggestioni ho
chiesto loro di lasciarmi il loro
disegno la loro opera Il risultato devo
dire dato è stato davvero strabiliante
decine di mondi interiori diversi appesi
alle pareti disegni di mamme di nonni di
bambini di ragazzi tutti
all'interno della bag che vi è stata
data all'ingresso avete trovato un
quadernino e una penna Forse qualcuno di
voi li ha già utilizzati bene Adesso è
il momento di utilizzarli voglio
tranquillizzare tutti perché so che
potrebbe insinuarsi il panico da non so
disegnare non serve saper disegnare
fatelo Come vi viene senza pensarci
troppo
vi do 15 20 secondi lo so non è
tantissimo ma ci proverete per
disegnarmi come siete oggi potete farlo
con o senza parole come preferite
chi sei
cosa sei
Qual è la forma più semplice e autentica
di te che riesci a immaginare
insegnate l'insegnante
via via che
terminate il vostro disegno la vostra
Opera
vi chiedo di alzare in alto i vostri
quaderni i vostri disegni di farceli
vedere
di essere anche un po' curiosi di
sbirciare quelli degli altri Ovviamente
senza copiare ormai le avete già
disegnati
non abbiate paura
Guarda Guardate quanti bei disegni tu
come li fate vedere da vicino
adesso
[Musica]
guardando quel disegno
ogni volta che calerà la sera avrete
sempre il vostro Faro la vostra luce e
la linea che vi ricorderà che siete
quel disegno cambierà Forse sì forse no
ma sapete cos'è che farà davvero la
differenza
ricordarvi sempre di dar voce a quella
leggerezza senza macini sul cuore Grazie
[Applauso]